as a 17-year old student of politic I
would like to ask how do each of the
party leaders believe they'll be able to
keep their promises of eliminating the
deficit without raising certain taxes or
making vast cuts to vital public
services Johnny thank you very much
indeed nick clegg Johnny I think it's
all about balance isn't it that's why I
don't think that you should be faced
Johnny with the stark choice of either
cutting too much
George Osborne and David Cameron's plan
is 450 billion pounds of cuts way beyond
what's needed or borrowing too much
which is Ed Balls and Ed Miliband's plan
they want to borrow 70 billion pounds
more than is necessary I think it's a
dismal choice cutting too much for
borrowing too much it's a balance and it
does me yes you need to reduce spending
but you also need to make those with the
broadest shoulders the wealthiest to pay
a bit more through the tax system to
balance the books that's the way you can
balance the books do it fairly also then
of course put money into public services
perhaps most especially the NHS which
does need more money because of the fact
we've got an ageing population so the
Liberal Democrat plan is a very simple
one we'll cut less than the
Conservatives and we'll borrow less the
Labour thank you very much indeed David
Cameron well first of all what I'd say
is that we've got a plan which is
working we've taken three million of the
lowest paid people out of tax and we've
got almost 2 million people back into
work but I think what's absolutely
crucial here is recognizing that what
our plan involves is balance we're going
to go on investing in the NHS every year
as we have done under this government
under the last Parliament will go on
doing that in the next parliament we're
going to find savings of one out of
every hundred pounds that the government
spends and if we need to do that for two
more years just as we've done for the
last five years but the alternative to
that plan is actually putting up taxes
and I don't want to do that I think if
we go back to the tax the waste the
spending and the debt all the things
that got us into a mess in the first
place we wouldn't help working people
we'd hurt working people
that's what Labour did last time and we
mustn't let it happen again
David Cameron thank you
Liam wood under our plans the deficit
will be cut from ninety billion to
thirty billion by 2020 we see no reason
to put arbitrary deadlines on cutting
the deficit the austerity experiment has
failed we were told that the deficit
would be eliminated within this
Parliament yet debt has gone up we faced
all of these ket's so much pain for so
little gained the banks have had a
bailout it's time now for the people to
have a bailout and it's time for us to
invest in public services and job
creation and to see an end to austerity
and cuts
yeah mwah - thank you tonight off Irish
well the question is right how can
anybody believe these promises on
cutting the deficit because this
coalition was put together to reduce the
annual deficit to zero that's why these
two guys got together it is still
running at 90 billion sterling every
year more remarkably and what no one
talks about is the national debt now
which have been going on for hundreds of
years and in this five years the
national debt has doubled from 850
billion to 1.5 trillion we need to make
cuts and there are some places we can
start we could easily cut 10 billion
pounds a year from the foreign aid
budget we could save another 10 billion
pounds a year by not paying over money
to Brussels every single day we could
end vanity projects like HS - that will
only benefit a tiny number of people
thus saving by the end of this
Parliament 4 billion pounds a year and
we need to revisit the Barnett formula
because frankly English and Welsh
taxpayers are getting a rotten deal and
we could save 5 billion pounds a year in
doing that there's a plan and a promise
that could be kept Faraj thank you very
much indeed
ed Miliband Johnny will cut the deficit
every year and as I said in the opening
we will balance the books but we'll do
it in a fairer and better way than has
been tried over the last five years
David Cameron promised to eliminate the
deficit and he failed so what we'll do
is first of all we'll have fair taxes so
we'll reverse a tax cut that he gave to
millionaires 43,000 pounds for every
millionaire in Britain secondly we will
have common-sense spending reductions
so outside key areas like education and
health spending will fall but thirdly
we'll do something else because your
living standards have fallen over the
past five years and that hasn't just
been bad for working people it's also
meant that government has hasn't had the
tax revenues coming in that's why this
government failed on the deficit so what
we'll do is by boosting living standards
that's the third part of our plan to
live within our means get the deficit
down and balance the books it's a fair
way it's a better way for our country
I've no van Thank You Leslie Bennett
well Johnny I think what we're offering
is not cuts we're offering the reversal
of austerity investing in your future
and the future of everybody in this room
and what we've been doing and looking at
the deficit is looking at this the wrong
way around
we've been slashing away at essential
public services and let's really think
about what austerity actually means
probably somewhere near you there's a
children's center or a library that's
closed think of a worker in say that
children's center
she used to be providing an essential
public service to your community
she used to be paying tax and national
insurance she had a modest amount of
income to bring to spend in the
community now that essential service is
gone
she's on Jobseeker's Allowance and
everybody is much poorer so what we're
saying is we do need to raise taxes on
those who aren't currently paying paying
their share multinational companies in
particular and rich individuals if they
pay their share in the world's sixth
richest country we can afford to have a
decent Society and Accord to have decent
public services Natalie Bennett thank
you little sturgeon Oh Johnny
cutting the deficit is important of
course it is but economic policy
shouldn't be an end in itself it should
be a means to people living better lives
and the factors austerity is pushing
people into poverty is undermining our
public services and it's holding back
economic growth and when economic policy
is doing all of that that policy needs
to change so I don't agree with the cuts
proposed by the Tories labour and the
Liberal Democrats I take a different
view we should have more dis pending
increases
over the next parliament it will take
slightly longer to eliminate the deficit
completely but the deficit would
continue to fall in each year of the
next Parliament but crucially that
alternative plan would mean that we had
resources to invest in infrastructure
and skills and innovation the things we
need to get our economy growing at
resources to invest in our public
services and in lifting people out of
poverty that kind of alternative plan
must be better than a blind commitment
to austerity that doesn't take any
account of the damage being done to our
society